[Music]
russian state television's tribute to
daria dugina killed in a car bomb on
saturday night
a signal to us all the presenter says
she died for her views she died for the
idea of the russian world
russia's top spy agency says this woman
was behind it an assassin from ukraine's
secret services they say identified as
natalia vovk who the fsb says traveled
to russia with her 12 year old daughter
in july to trail dugina living in the
same apartment block as her traveling to
the same patriotic festival which
duganer was leaving when the bomb went
off
vovs mini cooper photographed with a
selection of different plates escaping
across the border to estonia on sunday
supposedly just hours after the attack
took place
[Music]
it took the fsb just one day to solve
this murder though it should come as no
surprise that they point the finger at
ukrainian intelligence the
identification of the alleged assassin
on a russian hacker-led doxing site as a
member of the azov battalion also seems
rather convenient though the fsb has not
officially made that connection
themselves
ukraine has again denied all involvement
mikhail padalya who advises the
president tweeting that russian
propaganda lives in a fictional world a
ukrainian woman and her 12 year old
child were assigned responsible for
blowing up the car of propagandist
duganer surprisingly they did not find
the estonian visa on the spot vipers in
the russian special services started an
intra-species fight
in moscow patriotic youth groups
celebrated the day of the national flag
vladimir putin promising in a video
addressed the unwavering pursuit of
russia's interests
russia is a powerful independent world
power we are firm in pursuing on the
international arena only those policies
that meet the fundamental interests of
the motherland
in a letter to dario dugan's parents the
russian president called the attack a
vile crime her father the ultra
nationalist philosopher alexander dugan
called her a rising star at the
beginning of her journey
the question now whether and how russia
will seek vengeance
dana mcnay sky news moscow